[Musica]
bene vi parlerò di biodinamica
biodinamica e composta bio rappresenta
tutti gli elementi di venti di questo
pianeta dinamica perché a questi
elementi di 20 uniamo anche le forze che
governano il nostro globo la biodinamica
nasce da una filosofia la biodinamica si
pone un obiettivo principale la
differenza del biologico importantissimo
una pratica bellissima per fortuna che
oggi sta crescendo sempre di più la
biodinamica si pone un obiettivo in più
il biologico e diciamo fermo su un
concetto di mantenere nella maniera più
naturale possibile quello che c'è la
biodinamica si pone un altro obiettivo
oltre a questo molto importante per
altro è un pre requisito per accedere ad
una tecnica biodinamica la biodinamica
si pone l'obiettivo di ricreare una
fertilità del suolo nella nostra tenuta
agricola di quello che
che facciamo noi facciamo vino abbiamo
bisogno quindi di avere il miglior
prodotto possibile non si esce da questo
se vogliamo fare eccellenza noi dobbiamo
avere il miglior frutto possibile in
questo caso è la biodinamica ci aiuta in
questo la biodinamica nasce su si muove
su un concetto olistico chiamiamolo così
è un concetto che vede l'intero
ecosistema l'intero globo l'intera
tenuta se parliamo di questa frazione
dove noi operiamo come un sistema unico
un sistema dove tutti gli elementi
naturali sono importanti per cui se io
devo riportare la mia tenuta le mie
colture ad una fertilità ancestrale per
darmi questo frutto
bellissimo di cui ho bisogno devo
operare in maniera non diretta su una
singola pianta ma devo operare su tutto
l'ambiente che mi circonda questo è
molto importante perché oltre che
ottenere poi un risultato in termini di
prodotto otteniamo un risultato molto
importante che è quello di avere un
ambiente di curare un ambiente di
rispettare un ambiente dove via per cui
la biodinamica fa questo tenendo conto
di una serie di elementi che partono da
quello che ci circonda il cosmo vanno a
finire alla biodiversità fanno finire a
tecniche di aiuto alla natura per darci
questo frutto
ho voluto fare questo intervento anche
per un motivo spesso quando si parla di
di biodinamica diciamo alcune alcuni
pensieri si mostrano un po scettici
addirittura tacciano questa pratica di
stregoneria di esoterismo
allora vi dirò che non è affatto così
è una pratica che volendo tutti noi
potremmo applicare se abbiamo un nostro
orto qualcosa che che vogliamo coltivare
perché gli elementi sono semplici
quando parliamo di astri molti dicono ah
ecco arriviamo al concetto del cosmo
cosa può fare il cosmo lo vediamo dalla
luna la luna è un asso che influenza la
nostra vita in ogni momento influenza lo
vediamo dal mare le maree la luna riesce
ad avere un'influenza con la sua energia
sulle maree riesce a spostare una massa
enorme continuando con quello che accade
il ciclo femminile legato al concetto
della luna tutti gli elementi sono
legati tutti gli elementi a base di
acqua specialmente le piante fanno parte
di questi elementi sono composte di
acqua hanno la linfa per cui non è
stregoneria è una realtà noi dobbiamo
tener conto di questo alcune pratiche se
le facciamo in determinati momenti
creano la differenza poi la biodinamica
va avanti anche con il concetto della
biodiversità
niente di più naturale dobbiamo ricreare
un ambiente dove vediamo i nostri
insetti gli animali tutto fa parte di un
concetto di ritorno all'ance strali ta
di questi terreni
poi le pratiche di aiuto sono anche i
sovesci corno letame corno silice
composizioni che vengono applicate in
maniera molto vicino all'uomo alla
omeopatia piccole quantità diluite
dinamizza te in grosse quantità di acqua
date sui nostri terreni sui nostri
vigneti per fertilizzare piuttosto che
per polarizzare i raggi solari come nel
caso del corno silice tutto questo detto
in due parole si potrebbe parlare per
giorni di queste tecniche la cosa
migliore visitare una tenuta biodinamica
e riuscire a percepire l'energia che
riesce a darci un ecosistema che è stato
riportato alla sua concezione primitiva
ovviamente noi non facciamo questo
agendo in un ambito selvaggio tutto è
estremamente curato lo vedete nelle
immagini
abbiamo rivisto delle strane costruzioni
quelli sono gli alberghi per insetti
perché vengono costruiti e vengono
disposti nella tenuta affinché gli
insetti possono nidificare ricreare
biodiversità
questo è tutto molto molto bello era
solo un un flash per appunto per
ritornare su questo concetto che non
sono pratiche strane e la pratica più
naturale che esiste tant'è che ci siamo
incontrati con quello che poi viene il
dato è diventato un grande amico con il
maestro peppe vessicchio
lui oltre a sposare ovviamente
totalmente questi concetti sta facendo
anche qualcosa di più e sta lavorando
sul concetto della musica applicata al
all'influenza che può avere sulle
persone
lo sappiamo già ovviamente un brano
musicale ci può rilassare piuttosto che
a crearci tensione ma la cosa bella che
lui sta facendo e questa sperimentazione
sulle piante e su elementi vivi come il
vino e questo ci ha subito accomunato
compete facciamo siamo molto insieme a
parlare ore di queste cose facendo
esperimenti anche e la cosa funziona la
musica sono frequenze le frequenze sono
una cosa reale non le vediamo ma
esistono in questa stanza noi potremmo
dire che non c'è niente a parte noi
quello che vediamo non è così se
accendiamo una radio
ascolteremo della musica che non si
sente non si vede ma si sente quindi c'è
qualcos'altro
e allora tutto questo crea un influenza
su tanti elementi tra cui il vino è
stato molto bello tra l'altro un una
cosa che lui mi disse una volta eravamo
bevendo un bicchiere di vino mi fa
riguarda lo sai perché questo vino è
così buono perché la passione che ci
metti l'amore arrivano fino a questo
composto vivo che ne resta comunque
influenzato e ti restituisce questo
concetto in termini di armonia
di armonia naturale e molto bello questo
concetto certo quello su cui dobbiamo
stare attenti alle volte è capire se la
scienza attualmente dà risposte a tutto
quello di cui noi abbiamo bisogno
la scienza è fondamentale però alle
volte di fronte a concetti che non
riesce a spiegare si limita a dire che
non sono validi non esistono allora
bisognerebbe fare magari anche alle
volte un un passo indietro
dove ci sta portando specialmente nella
tecnologia chimica sotto questo stiamo
arrivando ad un risultato che volevamo
ci stiamo accorgendo che ci fa ammalare
piuttosto che ci sta creando un mondo
che non volevamo allora facciamo anche
una riflessione su questo un passo
indietro
mettiamoci in una posizione molto umile
anche nei confronti di quello che non
capiamo noi abbiamo una percezione di
quello che ci circonda dello 0,5 per
cento arriva al 5 per cento con
l'utilizzo delle tecnologie pensate solo
ai microbi non li vediamo non esistono
per noi attraverso lo strumento
riusciamo a capire che c'è un elemento
in più allora tutto questo è solo una
provocazione per dire che alle volte
forse ci dovremmo ricordare di socrate
che diceva tutto quello che so e di non
sapere
grazie a tutti